deep-fried rocket was that your idea no
changing them into crisps p5 Rockets
gone it's gone it's gone that was
announced that for lunch talking about
lunch I never wear the menus this is
look at menus and I can already hear I'm
starving
despite his rocket abomination and he
has definitely had a beneficial effect
on the food here so why if they're doing
a booming trade in the evening and
lunchtime still completely dead looking
at the bar menu I've got a good inkling
why three little words spring to mind
deep fried food if a Russian wants to
get a good reputation food has to be
consistently good throughout
it's like a chromatic turn miles away
it's a good good for you the restaurant
has completely spoiled by the ship
serving in the bar and I've never gonna
attract people from the bar to clean the
restaurant they will stop serving a
service the deep-fried rubbish on the
more placed bar menu is in danger of
completely undermining its new
hard-fought reputation service when
you've got such diverse menus is going
from the sort of first division straight
down to the fourth two dishes on the bar
menu is more expensive than your lunch
menu and the food on the lunch menu is
ten times more exciting than the food in
the bar I want to suggest incorporating
more of the restaurant menu into the bar
slowly or properly so anyone coming in
for a quick snack whatever it happens to
be it's an indication to how good is in
there for me if it helps the consistency
and it helps the speed of delivery then
it's no gamble yeah no more deep fat
fruit no and just to make sure I'm
putting the deep fat fryer out of harm's
way